- Get up here, I want to make sure all
this is my vlog, you'll
be on YouTube shortly.
Just
(audience laughs)
So Vlog, real quick.
These are old people.
♪ I'm addicted ♪
♪ To your skin ♪
♪ For the places that I've been ♪
- [Gary] Thank you.
(audience cheers, applauds)
I know that if somebody
here started a podcast
for this industry
and put out an episode every week,
and interviewed a thought leader
in this industry,
that even though only
700 to 15 hundred people
would listen to it,
because it's obviously
very niche in its content
then it would be the differentiator
of growing their business.
That it would lead to lead gen,
that there are people
that they're trying to
chase to get the account,
then in turn a year later would be
chasing them to be a guest on the show,
which then would inevitably lead
to them getting the business.
My friends, please understand
over the next period of
time as I talk to you
about some of these nuances,
that I am not a technologist.
That had I not been in business
that I wouldn't want to have necessarily
an Instagram or Snapchat
or LinkedIn account.
It doesn't come natural to me,
it's not necessarily what I want.
What I want is to sell stuff.
What I want is to run
a successful business.
What I want is to win.
And to me, if you sit in this room,
and you do not realize how extreme
the internet technology
revolution actually is,
you become vulnerable.
Watch this!
By show of hands, how many people here
now mainly watch Netflix or Amazon Prime
or what is called an OTT
HBO, mainly those
platforms, raise your hands.
Actually, please stand up.
Please?
I mean it.
I apologize, I know you're lazy
but stand up, I want people to see this.
(audience laughs)
I want people
Do not sit down yet and honestly
if you mainly watch
Netflix or Amazon Prime
or Hulu or YouTube,
guys, I just need
everybody to look around.
I have clients that are spending $80 bill
Baban, get up here.
Get up here, I want to make sure all
this is my vlog.
You'll be on YouTube shortly.
Just
(audience members laugh)
So Vlog, real quick.
These are old people, right?
(audience laughs)
I mean this is 30s and 40s
and 50s and 60s and 70s.
Look around, literally,
Jesus.
87 percent of this audience
doesn't even have the chance
to consume a commercial!
And the 13 percent that are sitting
that watch network,
when a commercial goes on,
they grab this.
$80 billion dollars spent
on commercials in America,
and nobody, and I mean nobody
is watching.
Cool, thank you.
- [Man] I really see that
there's so few people
that take advantage of what's out there.
- Because a lot of people hear
that stuff and think it's more like
the secret, like you just sit
and you dream it into existence.
- Right, right, right.
- It's got a very interesting stigma.
Listen, I for example, as you know,
don't love positioning myself
as a motivational speaker.
Even the content you just saw.
But no question,
the mindset is the operating
system of our lives.
- Right
- And I'm an
absolute believer in
cutting out negativity,
going on the offense,
positive thinking, what's the alternative?
Practicality, I'm a big
believer in that stuff.
- But, action is really
the biggest thing, huh?
- And I do believe that the right mindset
leads to the right actions
- Right.
- So yes, I do think you have
Listen, to me it's about getting
poison out of the system.
Right?
- Right.
- I mean, look, you know how many people
lose in your situation?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Right?
- Yeah.
- Because that's what they
decide to think about.
You didn't!
- Right.
- The end.
- It's fuckin' binary.
- Right.
- And so, one of the things I do often is,
the people around me that are
thinking about negativity,
I'm like, what's the alternative?
There's so much negat-
This scares the shit out of people.
- Right.
- You're positive, they're runnin' around
with their legs and complainin'.
Right?
- Right.
- So I'm with you, I couldn't agree more.
- Yeah.
- I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
- Real pleasure
bye, everyone!
- Alright.
- Good to see you, brother.
- Gary
I've been following you
for many, many years.
My name is Ed Rosenbaum
I really, really am thrilled
that I go to hear you today.
- Thank you, Ed.
That means a lot to me, sir.
- I'm going to email you,
I want to thank you a little bit.
- I would love that, thanks for
- I'm a little bit on the older side
- Nah, brother.
- I'm really ready to
- It's a mindset, brother.
- Well the mind is way down here.
- That's it, that's it!
It's a real pleasure.
Take care.
So, something to think about.
I'm like yo, bro, cool.
To me, it's like, of course,
but I definitely think June and July
for a
Just drove from Nashville to Chattanooga
beautiful day.
Bunch of calls within the office.
In New York, got a
shitload done on the phone.
Jammin' with Mickey, now
walking into the office
here at VaynerNooga.
It's a good day.
Had to give a good keynote
about Baban's mom.
About Baban's momma.
See what we get for the rest of the day.
Love you Vlog,
thanks for watching, really.
You know, I'm a big believer
that it's no different
than swimming or riding a bike.
Two things that didn't come natural to me.
I started swimming and riding a bike
late in my life.
You know, I don't think I started swimming
'til I was nine.
Because I feared them.
But the answer was literally to just
jump in the pool and start swimming.
To just skin your knee, right?
To take in a little water.
- Fail a little and then
- I just think you do
I just
I think the best thing
that could happen to you,
is if you hear this advice,
there's a networking event in town,
you go.
You put on your nice little VaynerMedia
nametag, you walk up, you see somebody,
you're inspired by my
five minutes with Gary.
You go up and go hi, to John.
And John looks at you and says,
"get the fuck outta my face."
I actually think that would be the
best thing that could ever happen to you.
- Yeah.
- I think the best thing
that could happen to somebody
when they fear something
is for them to taste
the thing they feared,
aggressively and immediately
when they try something.
- Okay.
- I think that it just eliminates
you'll literally be there
and whether you go crying in the bathroom,
or just like, becoming silent
or walking out of there,
or walking and getting a
cheeseburger for five
seconds and coming back,
I think the great thing
that would happen to you
is that you'd be like,
okay, well that happened, now what?
Once people understand and
taste the thing they fear,
it becomes a hell of a lot less scary.
We're
So we're doing it there.
- [Man] Yep.
- [Gary] And then
is this the hotel I stayed in last time?
Awesome, so we'll be able to make up
that 15 easy.
In real life?
- In real life so I told some guy
two months ago he looked just like you.
I could not
_ You weren't sure if it was
oh, no kidding, that's awesome!
- I know you know who I'm talkin' about.
He said, no I don't!
(laughs)
And I was like, I'm gonna
think of this guy's name.
And then, I swear it's like Facebook knows
what you're thinkin' about.
(laughs)
Every day I see you, and I'm like
guy I've ever met
in my life.
- What's your name?
- Keaton
- Keaton, such a pleasure, man.
Thank you, brother.
Take care, brother.
- [Man] Guy who runs it
- [Gary] Love it.
What up, Snapchat?
Hope you're doin' your thing.
Hope life is good.
Hope life is good, that's about it.
Oh, you put up everybody's brackets?
(crosstalk)
- We did a bunch of random brackets.
- [Gary] Oh, God.
(laughs)
I love it.
You become more important to the suppliers
which may give you buying
power on some other
another thing that happens
in desperate times is
I'll buy your strawberries but
next week when I buy the squash,
can I get a 20 percent discount?
Yes.
Now you're winning twice.
Now you're doing
something super authentic,
just got off with Farmer Joe,
boom, we film you making
it, it's super fun
and then everybody wants to try that soup
this weekend, or tomorrow, or tonight.
- Yeah.
- He should start a text messaging system
or email against it as well.
We use Facebook at first
to build awareness,
but then I don't want to keep paying them.
He has the texts, now he's like,
hey guys, the flash Friday,
the Facebook Flash Friday food is?
Farmer Joe's still stuck
with those peppers.
Last week we did the sauce,
this week we're doing the pizza.
See where I'm going?
Way I would do it is not more than
you're a slinging dealmaker,
it's that you're a creative.
With my passion for food,
I've come up with a
great concoction of yam
- [Man] Right, like what's in the basket?
- That's right.
Yam juice.
Baban's just pumped because he knows
this is gonna be a good piece of content.
So you don't see this
part but meeting with
a lot of small businesses
here in Chattanooga,
a big strategy of mine in the Southeast
is to do more business
with small businesses.
So, A, hit up VaynerMedia's website
if you feel that.
But the whole Alabama,
Florida, Georgia, Louisiana
this is, we're gonna use this office
to really start drilling
it in these kind of
25K to 250K scopes where we're just like
a guardian, a mentor.
We're breaking our own business
because we think there's a need,
and it feels good.
I don't know if you just saw the fire
and I'm sure he'll edit it but
there's a different high for me helping
that's what I did.
Helped my dad's small business.
I just know what to do,
when you don't have a whole lot of money.
- [Senator] Anybody this week
would you share with us the
names of the people you've messaged?
- [Zuckerberg] Senator, no, I would
probably not choose to
do that publicly here.
- [Senator] I think that may be what this
is all about,
your right to privacy.
- Just want to say one thing,
it's super fascinating
that we love to blame technology
for our actions.
(phone beep)
The right to privacy absolutely matters.
But that's not what the
conversation's about.
Like,
our choices, we don't see any ads that
don't have
people don't like wasting money,
people don't get it.
We love blaming technology.
- [Man] Can I include that
with a little word mark
to the side, in reference to
- I just
- testifying?
- Much more fun than blaming ourselves.
Dude, how are you?
- Nice to meet you, man.
Good, Gary V, I just wanted to say
thank you man.
- Hold on one second.
- I just wanted to say thanks.
I'm Nick from
I was on the show
- How are you?
Yes, yes.
- Yeah it's great to meet you
- It's a real
pleasure, man.
- I was hoping you might come out here.
- I came out!
Real pleasure, brother.
- Nice to meet you buddy
thank you so much.
- My pleasure.
What's up Vlog?
Great day.
Here with my homies
from Chattanooga office.
Headed to the team dinner now.
Great day of meetings, business,
had an incredible call with AJ just now
about VaynerSports.
We've been invited to the green room
with Josh Jackson, who's
gonna be a first rounder
so if you're watching the NFL Draft,
you're gonna see me
which is gonna be funny,
'cause I'm definitely gonna hack culture
and do something ridiculous like
livestream and get
kicked out or something.
Anyway, nonetheless, excited for the
dinner we're having now with the team
which is always the highlight for me
when I'm in 'nooga.
I don't like the sunsets.
(crosstalk, laughs)
I'm, when it comes to
visually seeing things,
I'm like fundamentally not
there's nothing on Earth
that I want to see.
I am the worst when it comes to travel.
I don't want to go to a single,
there's nothing I want to see.
Nothing.
Not one thing.
- What do you like to do when you travel?
- Lay on the beach,
for me?
Nothing.
Nothing is the best.
To me, beach
do nothing is like everything.
I don't want
The only thing that even begins,
and I would say it's one percent,
is like the pyramids might be interesting.
Just 'cause I'm like,
that's some crazy shit that
they were able to do that.
- [Man] I remember when
my Mom first got Netflix.
- [Man] TiVo?
- [Female] Yeah.
(crosstalk)
- TiVo.
By the way
- [Man] My Mom bought TiVo in 1999.
- Yeah, so did I.
I will tell you that TiVo
Tivo, out of every technology
in the history of my life,
in my life, internet included,
TiVo was the one that took
me the longest to comprehend.
I was like
(group laughs)
I couldn't put the
pieces together, I'm like
what?
You grew up your whole life and
you're like, I'm like, what?
I can pause normal TV?
It's like
(mimics explosion)
Wait, when I have to go
pee during a Jets game
I couldn't wrap my head around it.
Or, you can make 70,
I'm gonna go pretty extreme.
Or, 130, that range, talking about skiing,
water polo, wine,
I'm fuckin' fascinated by it, man.
Because I think as people start learning
more about e-commerce,
as Amazon and Shopify
made commerce longtail,
as social media makes media longtail,
I think, as a business owner that
wants to build a big empire,
I love the fact that for all eight, 19
that work at Vayner,
if that's what they choose, that's cool.
I think that's super amazing,
so I think we hear it being,
back to like technology and changes,
and we're like, well so
few people are gonna be
but I don't think that's
the right argument.
The right argument is not me,
or Jenners or
the people that are with millions of fans.
It's what's the Mendoza Line?
Because I think eventually
people will realize,
wait.
If you keep your expenses down,
and this is why I'm
fascinated by cities and
Chattanooga, no tax.
Making 88 here selling through Shopify
and getting shoutouts from brands
is a totally different life.
And I know some of you lived it,
in New York with us, right?
Then making 157 working
at Vayner in New York.
And, comma, you're your own boss
you talk about the one thing you love
Strawberry Shortcake.
You talk, you love Strawberry Shortcake.
She's your favorite,
and that's what you get to talk about,
24 hours a day, I think it's super cool.
Things like college debt
and things like doing what you love
will become more practical.
And I think that one of the reasons
I want to be pro-employee and all this is
I want to get my pattern recognition down
for 20 years from now, because
the requirements of having
good people work for you
will be greater and greater and greater
because none of us grew
up with that expectation
and it's not deep in our DNA.
But, they will.
Yeah I mean we are brainwashed
in our current alternative.
People really thought
college was a good idea.
All of you in here, at your ages,
thought it was a good idea.
It wasn't a good idea.
Now, it was a great idea
if the following happened.
Your parents paid for it,
you had fun.
But if you're not part of that,
not as interesting.
♪ I wanna take you ♪
♪ Places that you ain't never been ♪
♪ Show you the world that
you ain't never seen ♪